>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
>> I first became familiar
with Claire Messud's work
when I had the privilege of
reviewing The Emperor's Children
in 2006 at a time when I
was at the Buffalo News
as the editor of the paper.
I really liked the book.
I gave it a positive review.
So did everyone else in the world.
The New York Times review
called Claire Messud a novelist
of unnerving talent.
The book was widely celebrated,
named one of the Times's best books
of the year, 10 best books of
the year, and was long listed
for The Man Booker Prize.
Claire Messud's new book,
The Burning Girl, is,
according to NPR's review, now I'm
quoting, a subversive commentary
on the stories we tell about women
and the way those stories
circumscribe our lives.
Edgar Allan Poe wrote that the death
of a beautiful woman is
unquestionably the most poetical
topic in the world.
In her new book, Messud
says, "not to us."
I give you Claire Messud.
[ Applause ]
>> Claire Messud: Good
afternoon, everybody.
Thank you for coming.
It's wonderful to be here.
And this festival is perhaps
the most exciting festival.
I came here first for my last
novel, The Woman Upstairs.
And there's something about the
energy of-- it was already indoors,
and there's something about
the energy of everybody
who loves books gathering
under one roof
in this incredible way
for this incredible day.
And I just feel very
grateful to be part of it.
So thanks for being here.
And thought what I would do is tell
you a little bit about my novel
and where it came from and what
I thought I was trying to do.
And then I can take questions
from you guys if you have any.
The Burning Girl is set in
Massachusetts in a small town,
fictional town called Royston
about an hour north of Boston,
not far from the New
Hampshire border.
And it's told by a
young girl, Julia,
who at the time of telling is 17.
She's just going into her
last year of high school.
But she is telling the story
of her friendship with Cassie.
And the girls were best friends
in childhood, and in the course
of adolescence, their
friendship has--
it unraveled, and thereby,
hints a tale.
And I wanted, in writing
this story, to--
I was trying to do something
I hadn't done before.
And I don't know if anybody in
the-- every time you write a book,
you're trying to do something
you haven't done before.
The writer, Peter Carey,
who's a very wonderful writer,
if you're not familiar with
his work, go out and grab it.
He's one of the most
exhilarating writers.
Every book is a new adventure.
Each book is a completely imagined
world and really different.
And he has said, if it doesn't
seem impossible, why bother trying?
And I really take that to heart.
I think that each time, you know,
each time I set out to do something,
I'm not really sure whether I can.
And that was true of this
book in a different way
than each of my earlier books.
But in some ways, this book
is a sort of companion piece
to my last novel, The Woman
Upstairs, which is a novel
about women's friendship in midlife.
It's about an elementary
school teacher who is an artist
in her spare time who
befriends a woman
who is a successful artist,
and how that unfolds.
And this is very different, but
it's also about female friendship.
And some of the themes, I
think, overlap, themes about,
I'll talk more about
them in a minute,
but about how we know each
other and don't know each other.
But in writing this book, the
challenge that I was setting
for myself is that I wanted
to write an archetypal story
in a different way.
So I wanted it almost-- I
wanted it to be, if you will,
a fable of American
girls' adolescence.
In that sense, the account of an
almost universal experience, right,
a distillation of an experience
that almost everybody goes
through at some time, but grounded
in the specificities of two, to me,
very real girls, that I've imagined.
And in the telling to hold
the archetype up to the light,
if that makes sense, to sort
of hold it up and ask questions
about the stories that
we think we know.
I think that somewhere along the
line, and of course being me,
I cannot remember where, which seems
in this internet age an
all too common problem.
I read it somewhere.
There is a source somewhere.
But darned if I know.
But I read, when I was working on
the book, I read an article about,
I guess it was about neurology,
it was about how the eye
and the brain relate.
And I learned that, in
fact, at any given moment,
our brain processes only about
30% of what our eye sees, right?
So our eye actually sees the
whole picture, and our brain,
which is more efficient, plucks
about 30%, sort of 30% points of it,
and then fills in the rest with what
our brain knows from experience.
And, I mean, if you think of it,
that when you are a grown-up,
you very rarely lie in bed and
think that that's a monster
across the room when
it's your laundry, right?
Because you've had a lot of
experience of looking at the pile
in the corner and thinking,
I think that's a monster,
but I know it's the laundry,
so your brain just does
that for you and skates right over.
But when you're sort of four and
you don't have years and years
of experience, you
think it's a monster
because your brain can't fill it in.
So I was very interested by
this, by this revelation because,
or this fact, I guess
it wasn't a revelation
to the scientist, whatever.
It was a revelation to me.
I was very interested
because I realized that we do
that in life all the time.
And that somebody starts to tell
us a story about someone, you know,
did you hear about,
you know, Joe and Beth
and Joe's been having an affair, and
that's just found out, and we think,
I know how that story goes, I
know how that story goes, right?
But the number of times that
we do it, we just assume
that we already know the ending.
And that is-- each of us may
do that slightly differently.
But we do it because
we are as much made up.
Now, this is a little
sentence I came up with
that I'm sort of proud of.
But it doesn't actually
say what I want it to.
But never mind.
But we are as much made up of our
literarily lived lives as we are
of our literally lived lives, right?
Right? There's a little echo there.
That's nice, right?
But by which I mean that we
are made up of all the stories
that we take in, whether we
read them, whether we hear them,
whether resee them on TV,
whether they're in the news,
whether they're told in our
community or by our friends.
All those stories,
we internalize them.
We may forget them, but we distill
them and they're part of us.
And when we approach a narrative,
we bring all of that
experience to bear.
And often, we think, I
already know this story.
And so part of what, part of--
there are lots of ways in
which that's interesting to me.
But part of what's interesting
is this symbiotic way, you know,
we talk about how the stories
we tell reflect our culture.
But the stories we tell also
define our culture, right?
It's the symbiotic back and forth
in between what we all already know
from the stories we've internalized
and then the stories that we tell
with that knowledge in mind.
And so for me, this
story is obviously
on some level very simply the
story about two girls going
through adolescence from
the ages of 12 to 15,
told somewhat with the
retrospect of a couple years.
And it's a very simple story.
And on some other level, it's
trying to question what a story is,
how we make up a story, how each of
us in our different subjectivities
in which, you know, each of
us is trapped in who we are.
If you go back to the 18th century
German philosophers, there was Kant
who wrote a lot about subjectivity.
Then there was a guy called Fichte
who believed you really just--
there is no table except
the table each of us wills.
Like there isn't actually
anything out there.
I'm not going there.
I'm not going that far.
I believe this is holding,
this is holding up the papers.
We're okay.
But there is some way in which each
of us is trapped in
our own subjectivity.
So it's the Rashomon thing.
Has anybody seen the
Rashomon, the film, right,
that's the different perspectives,
and the story is different
depending where you stand.
So it's both-- I'm getting
a little bogged down.
I need to open up.
Okay, but I would just say, it's
like, for me, I recently saw, again,
the Nina Simone documentary, I
don't know if anybody has seen that,
but if you haven't, I
highly recommend it.
But I thought as I was watching it,
what I was trying to
do was like jazz.
That there's a very simple melody.
And the simple melody has to be, if
not recognizable, easy to follow.
But then I'm riffing on the melody.
Now, of course, another way
of thinking of this, which is,
you know, why it's a risk,
is that you could say,
she's just writing cliches and
disappointing us narratively.
Like she's writing cliches, and
then it doesn't end the way it's
supposed to.
But hey. So I just wanted to share
the epigraph of the book with you.
So I took the epigraph
from an Elizabeth Bishop
poem called Casabianca.
And it is, itself, a
commentary on an earlier poem,
a 19th century parlor poem called
Casabianca, the first lines
of which may be familiar to some.
But a parlor poem was something
that was recited in living rooms.
Like all kids used to know
these poems in the 19th century
and when there was no TV and no
iPhones, your kids would stand up
and recite the poems for you
as an entertainment before
they played the piano.
Or maybe after they
played the piano.
So the original poem
is the boy stood
on the burning deck once
all but he had fled.
The flame that lit the battle's
wreck, shone round him or the dead.
Does that ring a bell to some?
Yeah. So it's a poem based on an
actual event about a boy who was
on a ship with his father.
His father was the captain.
There was a battle.
His father was dying.
The boy was waiting for his dad
to say, you can abandon ship now.
But his dad didn't say that
because his dad was dying.
And so the boy went
down with the ship.
And it was a sort of famous
incident because he was a child.
There was the British comic,
Spike Milligan did a version,
which is the boy stood
on the burning deck,
once all but he had fled twit.
Anyway, but the Elizabeth
Bishop poem sort
of takes it to a slightly metalevel.
Loves the boy stood on
the burning deck trying
to recite the boy stood
on the burning deck.
Loves the Sun stood stammering
elocution while the poor ship
in flames went down.
Loves the obstinate boy.
The ship, even the
swimming sailors who would
like a schoolroom platform too
or an excuse to stay on deck,
and loves the burning boy.
And that's where the
title of the book comes
from is not the burning
boy, but the burning girl.
And the reason why is that in
the Elizabeth Bishop's poem,
there's both the original boy
standing on the burning deck,
and there's the boy standing on the
deck that would be like this, right?
Stammering elocution,
trying to recite the poem.
And for me and the book, both girls
are burning girls in different ways.
One is a narrator, one is
the actor or the person
to whom things happen
or who does things more.
But both are trapped in a
bond of love and of loyalty.
And one of the things I
wanted to raise questions
about in the book is what
does it mean to love someone?
Who does it mean to be loyal?
And these are questions posed in
this book about teenage girls.
But they're questions
about being human.
It's not just-- these are questions
that we face all our lives long.
The inspiration for the
book, the inspiration
for the book was multiple.
It always is.
I always think it's
like being a magpie.
You pick up, you know, I take
that handbag, I take that scarf,
I take the light on your hair
back there and I put it together
and I try to make something of it.
On the one hand, when I was
a kid, we lived in Australia.
And we left when I was nine.
And because I'm that
old now, I kept in touch
with my friends by writing letters.
And several years later
when we were all teenagers,
we were all still pen pals.
I was still pen pals
with three or four girls.
And the friends wrote to me and
told me the story of something
that had happened to a girl in our
class who had been a friend of mine,
but with whom I wasn't in touch.
And it was a story that I heard only
in fragments, and only partially.
And it was a story that ended in
that case with our classmate dying.
And I was-- it's not
the story in the book.
And I was haunted thereafter
all my life by the question,
not just by the story itself,
but by my sense of the sort
of hovering fragility of the story,
that I was putting it together
from these pieces that I had heard,
but I didn't ever actually
know for sure.
So I had a version, my friends
had versions, they were kids
at the time, so how much were they
really told, how much was rumor,
how much was, you know,
how much was invented?
And I went laterally and
looked at the press clippings,
and the story in the press
was completely different.
And my first thought was, wow,
I totally misremembered
everything I was told.
And then I remembered the
ways, like I realized, no, no,
I was told what I was told.
And then this is the official
story, this is like version 5.
This is a completely different,
you know, and so for me,
that was a story that I had-- not
the actual story, but the experience
that I wanted to try to write about
in fiction for many, many years,
for like probably 20 years.
And when I sat down finally and
wrote The Emperor's Children,
which I started initially in
2000, and then began in 2002,
I was debating, will I try to
tell some version of this story?
So that part has been
with me a long time.
And then the other part
is I'm a mom with kids,
including a daughter,
and nieces and nephews.
And I have been living, as maybe
it's true for some other people
in the audience, I've
been living a number
of years now in teenager land.
Not with the same perspective that
I had when I was going through it,
but with a different perspective,
which is the perspective of somebody
who sometimes thinks at least
I know how the story is going
to go ahead of time.
But I'm not in a position
where I can ever say, you know,
that's a thing parents
really can't do.
You really can't say don't, you
know, I can see what's going
to happen, you know,
three years, you know,
you just have to sit
quiet and bear witness.
That's a parent's job.
So watching what my daughter went
through in middle school was part
of-- was very powerful for me.
I saw her going through
things that I had--
versions of which I
had gone through.
And I was struck by how so much
has changed since my youth,
and nothing has changed, right?
That yes, there are cell phones
and Facebook and Snapchat and
but the emotions and the passions,
it is like a fellow, right?
A fellow was a long time ago.
The world has changed a lot.
But jealousy still looks
a lot like a fellow.
And by the same token,
the passion and the grief
and the terrible disillusionment
that teenage girls go
through in their friendships
hasn't changed at all.
The narrative is actually, is
divided into three sections.
And the first section
takes place the summer
after 6th grade, the
summer before 7th.
And at that point, Cassie and
Julia are still very close.
I mean, they're best friends.
They've been best friends
since nursery school.
And they spend the summer,
for a number of reasons,
they're spending the
summer together.
And Cassie gets injured.
And then they sort of have
to change their activities.
And they end up going into the woods
and finding an abandoned asylum
that they knew was there and
playing imaginary games there.
For me, that section
is fully in childhood,
in a time when imagination
is licensed,
the making up of stories is
considered free and creative
and is sort of culturally
sanctioned.
That's what we want kids to
do is to make up fictions.
And our fictions are sort of-- the
things kids play are often heroic
and they're influenced by fairy
tales and they're influenced
by Greek myths and they're
influenced by all of the
of the stories that fill our
childhoods in which animals,
animals aren't just animals, animals
are actor with opinions and sort
of symbolic import, and, you know,
the way that things happen
sequentially doesn't always need
logical explaining.
Because when you're a
kid, you just take it.
Whatever happens happens.
And if it doesn't make sense,
you'll understand someday.
You're not trying to
pin a logic on it.
put it in a context.
And that's the world that they're
living in at the beginning.
The middle section I think of
as sort of time passes is a kind
of transitional time in which
they're entering the world,
the girls are entering the
world, and things become real.
There's a Halloween section,
Halloween bit in there.
I feel like that moment, I
don't know if you remember
in your own lives or in lives of
people you love, the first year,
you don't go out trick-or-treating,
right?
When the magic is passing.
And the terrible wistfulness
that you feel as a kid,
but you also can't do it anymore.
Or else you do it in
the most cynical way,
which is you don't dress up
at all and you just go around
and raid the candy
bowls of the people
who have left their candy outside
and come home with a huge bag
of candy that you don't even eat.
So that's a sort of middle section.
And then the third section is a time
in which the girls are in 9th grade,
they've nominally entered a sort
of more adult, more adult time.
But they're making up
stories more than ever, right?
I think without realizing it.
Because when we are adults, we think
we don't live in a childish world
where there are knights and fairies,
and, you know, swans talk to us.
We live in a world that's
completely rational and orderly.
And we don't make up stories.
And yet if you think
about every day, you know,
if you think about when
you're walking down the street
and some man you find attractive
says, "oh, hey, are you going to be
at that lunch thing tomorrow?"
And then you walk away and you
think, I think, I think he likes me.
Maybe he likes me, right?
Well, you're just making
up a fiction
because you have no idea
whether he likes you.
He may have just been being
polite, or he may want you to be
at the lunch thing torso he
can borrow some money from you.
You have no idea, right?
So we move into a supposedly
logical rational world
in which we are actually projecting
our own version of stories
onto what's around
us the whole time.
And that's what happens both
for Cassie and for Julia,
not least because Julia is
no longer so close to Cassie.
They've moved apart.
They're moving in quite
different worlds.
And so Julia is recounting what's
happening or what's happened
to Cassie from afar, filling
in what she thinks she knows
because she thinks she
knows Cassie so well.
I should soon stop and open it
to the audience for questions.
But I just, I wanted to-- I have a
couple more things I wanted to add.
And one is that I've described this
as a children's book for grown-ups.
And then people say,
well, what do you mean?
And I think what I mean is that when
I talk about the children's world,
because another joy of being
a parent has been reading,
re-reading children's books, reading
and re-reading children's books
with my kids over all those years.
You enter, you experience children's
books with a sort of immediacy
without asking-- without asking--
immediacy, mystery and wonder.
Just experiencing it without asking
certain analytical questions.
And I certainly feel
as a-- I'm now 50.
And I feel that if you had asked me
at 30 or at 50, I would have said,
life is a process in which
you know more and more
and things become clearer
and more orderly
and you have a better
sense of the world.
And at 50, I can say, that
is just complete crap, right?
I feel as though the world is more
mysterious and more full of wonder.
Some of it is dark.
But the world is full of mystery.
There are more things in
Heaven and Earth ratio
than are dreamed of
in our philosophy.
And, you know, it's
something that I wanted
to have Julia not be telling her
story from the age of 30 or the age
of 40 because I wanted her
still to be close enough
on the childhood end, right, I feel
like I have that experience as I'm
at an older, but I wanted Julia
to be at the childhood end
where she's still, to quote
Wordsworth, trailing clouds
of glory, where she's still
inhabiting in some way
that child's logic, that way
of understanding the world,
even as she has passed
into an understanding
of herself as a grown-up.
And I thought, I worked hard to try
to make her language fairly simple.
But, you know, some
of the people writing
about the book have said she's
too articulate for a 17-year-old.
And sometimes they say those are
all the experiences and feelings
that I remember having at that time,
but I would never have
expressed them.
And to which I sort of feel
a little thrill of pleasure
because I feel isn't that
actually what art is for?
And what art should try to do is
express elusively the things we all
feel, even if we wouldn't
say them out loud.
And I'll finish just by
saying when I decided,
I had already decided I wanted to
be a writer when I was like five,
and my parents gave me a
little kid's typewriter
for my sixth birthday.
Very annoying child, I'm sure.
But I thought that children
weren't taken seriously enough.
And I wanted to write
grown-up books for children.
That was my aim when I was a child.
And Watership Down was the sort
of symbol, that was the book
that I held up, was like I
want to write books like that.
But now at this point, I feel
as though there's some return
to a sense that we, in
this moment in our culture,
and it's a broader conversation
for another day, but there is a ton
of really wonderful YA
fiction in the world
that didn't exist when I was young.
But one of the things that we've
done as a culture is literally
to separate off young people
from the mainstream bookshelves.
And we put them in a corner
where we send our teenage kids.
And then it's like
putting them behind a gate.
We don't think about them,
we don't talk about them,
and we don't consider, we don't give
equal weight to the inner lives,
the doubts, fears, philosophies
and personhood of young people.
We just sort of shut them away.
And so part of what I wanted to do
in this book is bring those girls
into the light, as it were,
of a grown-up readership.
And that's The Burning Girl.
So thank you.
And I'm happy to answer any
questions that people might have.
[ Applause ]
Or not. There must be one.
Margaret?
>> The first we is always
the icebreaker, right?
I'm sure there will be more.
Do you have a reader or a kind
of reader in mind when you write?
Or do you write for yourself?
Or do you have a sort
of ideal reader?
>> Claire Messud: That's
a good question.
And one I don't really
know how to answer.
I think in a funny way, when
I'm working on something,
I'm writing in service
of the story, right?
It's a question of what is the best
point of view or the best voice
or the best vehicle for
telling the story itself?
In this case, exceptionally,
I did have a reader in mind.
Not solely, but my daughter is 16,
and a very, a big reader, you know?
She's a lifelong, very
serious reader.
And she was one of the very first
readers of the manuscript for me.
And she gave me some great notes,
largely about the way
the kids spoke.
And she said, no, no, no, nobody
would speak like that, no, no, yeah.
And then she, you know,
so she was a--
her voice was really
important to me.
But that's an exceptional
case, in a way.
It's not usually--
that's not usually so.
Thank you.
Anybody else?
Don't run.
>> Your mentioning of magpie,
you think about a woman upstairs,
and for those who haven't read,
I'll try to be kind of vague,
but one artist takes the experience
of another person and
uses it in her art.
And I know that there are authors
who think anything is fair game.
I can take anything and use it.
And I just wondered what
your perspective on that was.
>> Claire Messud: You know,
that's why that's in there is
because I think it's one of the sort
of central dilemmas for an artist
of any kind, of what actually is
acceptable to use for your material.
And, you know, we think of it in
novelistic terms often of especially
with young writers, and I teach,
and often with young writers,
it's a real quandary if I'm going
to write stories about my parents
that they might someday
read, how do I go ahead?
And, you know, as a teacher, you
say you have to write the stories,
and then we'll cross that
bridge when we come to it.
And I do, I think it is about each
artist has to find their own balance
of what they feel okay with.
And I think people-- there's a real
spectrum, and people feel, you know,
you think of Eugene O'Neill, who
long days journey into night,
he just hung onto it until the
protagonists were dead, right?
I mean, he just, he wrote it
and then he just hung onto it.
But there are other people
who are much more comfortable just
having it out there come what may.
So I think it's really
an individual--
each person has to make
their peace with it.
Thank you.
>> Thank you for your discussion.
It was interesting.
How hard was it, or what was it
like going from a book about women
in the middle of their
life, in that perspective,
to moving back toward women,
young women, those are children,
and was it easy or was it just
kind of what you writers do?
>> Claire Messud: Well, I think,
I mean, interestingly, in my case,
you know, somebody said to me,
how did you do all the research
about the pop songs and stuff?
And I was like, well, I drive my
kids everywhere, so, you know,
it's just what they insist
on putting on the radio.
So I think in some ways, it
isn't really the same, it isn't--
just because of the nature of
my daily life, it wasn't a move
like suddenly trying
to write something set
in 1850 in Japan, you know?
I'm a woman in midlife.
I have a daughter who's a teenager.
They're very different experiences.
And the experiences of my own
and my daughter's experiences are
in no way those of any of the
characters in either novel.
But just as a sort of [inaudible]
or world, it didn't feel
like such a big leap in that case.
Thank you.
>> Yeah, so you had
mentioned that the story upon
which The Burning Girl was based on,
you know, you had been carrying it
in your head for a long time.
I'm sure you've been carrying
a lot of other stories,
even before you wrote
Emperor's Children.
What was it that made you say, okay,
now is the time to choose this story
over everything else in your
head, now is the time to put this
on paper, to make that commitment?
>> Claire Messud: And
yes, I think it was--
the magpie thing works
up to a point,
and then it's almost more
than a composting thing.
So it's like you put in the
eggshells and you put in the,
you know, peelings, and then
at some point, a shoot comes up
and something is growing.
And I think it was really that
sense, that I had had this,
and I didn't quite know
where to go with it.
And then watching our kids go
through this time, and as I said,
not just our daughter
and son, but our nieces
and nephews watching
these experiences,
it suddenly seemed
pressing and urgent in a way
that connected to this story.
And I guess it sounds sort of
abstract, but I really do believe
that this time and these
middle school years,
it's when we're forged as people.
It's when whatever happens in those
years marks us for good or ill
and shapes who we will
become, et cetera.
I always say, if you're having
trouble with any, you know,
if you're having trouble
with a person,
just picture them in
seventh grade, right?
And suddenly everything
becomes clear, right?
I mean, picture say the leader of
our country, picture middle school,
like suddenly many things
become clear, right?
So I think having those
years up close in front of me
and feeling the urgency
of them was part of it.
>> Thanks very much.
>> Claire Messud: Thank you.
>> Yeah, with the courage born
of ignorance, I see so much.
I was recently at a book
sale at a thrift store,
and there were just
racks and racks and racks
of dystopian novels aimed at--
I just would like to pitch
out the idea that the universe
in which we live is enough of a
dystopia, and we're robbing kids
of the ability to figure
out what's going on now
by projecting what's
going into the future.
Would you care to comment on that?
>> Claire Messud: Yes, sir.
So if everybody heard the
question or the comment,
it was about the vast
range of dystopian fictions
that are available in book form and
in other forms also for young people
to read, and to not be focusing
on our dystopian reality.
You know, I'm a reader who
always wants to be in reality.
I'm not somebody for whom fantasy--
there are some fantasy
books that I love,
but it's not my primary
mode as a reader.
And so I have to take
it from people I know
for whom it is the primary
mode, that sometimes it's almost
like Glenn Gould playing the piano
and putting on the vacuum cleaner.
You know, he used to do that.
And it helped him.
He said it helped him hear better.
I think there are some readers
for whom all of the issues
of our actual society are set in
better relief in an imaginary world,
that they actually, they can
actually see them more clearly
if they're set in an
imaginary time and place.
That's not the case for me.
So I'm with you.
I feel that will are so many stories
to tell right here right now.
So thank you, sir.
And I think that will be the--
this will be the last
question, I imagine.
Yes, sir?
>> You have written about
two middle school girls.
Would you posit that their
experience and your conclusions
that you draw from it are very
different from middle school boys?
>> Claire Messud: You know, it's
a really interesting question.
I think to which my
answer would be yes and no.
Unhelpfully.
I think in some ways it
depends on the kids, right?
It depends so much on the
individual and the temperament
and the dynamics between
individual kids.
And as a rule, as a rule, you could
say maybe it's a little different
for boys than girls.
Although I don't know if there's
anyone here who's read David
Mitchell, the author of Cloud Atlas,
wrote a wonderful book
called Black Swan Green,
which is about adolescent boys,
interactions that read very--
when I read it, it struck me as very
familiar from my girl experience.
And so I think it really,
it depends.
I'd say as a writer, I'm a
great believer in character.
I have many interests.
Language, the music of language,
metaphor, da da da da da.
But when I'm really interested
in, the bottom line, is people,
and how people are in the world,
who makes us who we
are and how we behave.
And so I think the groundedness
of each person in their place,
in their time, in their
dynamic, is what makes the story.
And gender is some small part of
that, but not the whole thing.
Thank you.
Okay, thank you very
much, everybody.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.